there's a famous line in rocky when
when uh his trainers like you know women
weaken legs right and so he didn't want
rocky to blow load before his fight is
that something common
in like the ufc like before a big fight
are you just completely abstinent for as
long as you can or what's this
what's this are you blowing those before
you go into the ring to relax
i got a theory on that and it's not
proven but that's what
that's what i truly believe because a
lot of people ask me about that
i believe the more you do it the more
testosterone it is so the more you do it
the better it is
the more you you evacuate the better it
is because
your body will produce more and however
it will i think it will raise your
testosterone
and i don't think it's a good idea to do
it the day of the fight
of course not but before or the day
before or i don't think it really matter
okay so you would think scott was the
most dangerous guy on the planet because
he'll jack off like nine
times in a day yeah i did it before the
podcast
yeah you probably have a very high
testosterone level i think so
that's the problem i think it's a good
thing i think it's actually a good thing
okay that's why scott can't fight
anybody because he can never go a day
without jackie
it will probably follow the
you will probably fail the uh
performance enhancing drug testing
right it's through the roof dude
i'm just that's right it's called
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon
and buy stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
yeah yeah
dude